I become more and more convinced every
day that Switzerland is the best map
country in the world I mean look at this
I'm just up in some rural like village
with just a few people and it's mapped
in 3D not to mention the perfect detail
on all of these mountains here's a
little town of 4 000 people in the Alps
and look at how detailed this is like I
feel like I'm flying a drone in this
Village here they are flying a little
plane around their country photographing
it in different wavelengths so they can
make the most accurate looking map
possible the Swiss government puts out
these little documentaries on how they
do all of this and I can't stop watching
them even though they're in a different
language now Google Earth deserves a lot
of props for all of this too but the
fact is it is so fun to just roam around
this country